Fear of speaking is a common thing that everyone goes through.
And so I decided that Toastmasters, give it a shot,...
...and teach myself to speak in public.
My club, they said, "Why don't you go in competitions?"
I don't even know there were such a thing as competitions for public speaking,...
...but then the bug sort of bit...
...and I really liked the sport of competing.
It's 30,000 people all over the world who all have a message, who all have a speech.
It goes from the club, then the area, then the division,...
...then the district, then the semifinals,...
...and now it's the top nine speakers.
Best speakers in the world.
Before I even do a speech, I have to really have a reason for giving that speech.
I don't just randomly throw speeches together.
Anybody can do a speech, but I think the passion that you have behind it...
...and connecting with your audience makes a great speech.
Trust is a Must, Ryan Avery.
Oh, he's so handsome.
You have an obligation as a speaker to go up there...
...and not just send something that you care about,...
...but something that can really change the lives of people.